[Music]
well good afternoon everyone that for
you guys for joining our session here on
considerations for migrating workloads
to the Google cloud let me give you a
little background on myself first my
name is Charles Wright I am the I am a
managing director for Deloitte cloud
engineering team a little background
about myself I started in data center
transformation right a long time ago
when data centers were cool about 15
years ago and my background
predominantly was in workload
transformation and data center all right
so I spent a lot of years sleeping on
data center floors migrating workloads
okay and as anybody who has ever worked
in that kind of business you spent a lot
of time away from your families right a
quick story about my data center
experience I was at a Dallas data center
doing migrations for enterprise client
and I spent three days there straight we
didn't smell too good at the end of the
third day and we were literally eating
on the data center floor
I mean pizzas hot dogs we were ordering
barbeque it was bad and the data center
team came to us and said you can't eat
on a data center floor this is a
violation of policy I said yeah but
we've been here three days and we
haven't gone home and we haven't eaten
we haven't done anything and they said
well we're right next door to the police
station so if you don't take this food
out in here you're going to jail so at
that point I realized that data center
in a town solid ation was not more
important than going to jail so we took
the food out and you know and move
forward but that's kind of been my
background and what I've been doing for
the last 15 years right
prior to working at Deloitte I had a
start up call adding data which is why
I'm wearing the shirt today added data
was a software product designed to move
enterprise workloads to the cloud we
were recently acquired in January so
this is my first speaking engagement
under the Deloitte banner so please be
nice to me I'm not used to working for a
giant firm I'm still in start-up mode so
so I'm getting used to working for a big
company so so part of our go-to-market
was around building enterprise grade
technology to answer the challenge of
transformation to cloud right so a lot
of folks if you know I'm old you know
don't be fooled I'm very old that's what
happens when you get acquired you know
you can get pretty you know though the
makeover and everything else so I spent
a lot of time solving a lot of these
challenges for decades right and anybody
who's ever done this that's not easy
okay and it's not just the technology
right people can make cool software to
answer problems and deal with challenges
the challenge comes with business
understanding the business reason why
transformation exists and that's what
makes it complicated because I can make
software that can move thousands of
workloads but if your business can only
take one workload moving them up then
that's just what happens right so what
I'm here to talk about today is
understanding really what the
complexities are this type of business
and really understanding how to get
there know how we do it right that's the
reason why I'm here today so let's let's
talk about it
so let's if you look at specifically the
cost associated with transformation
right this is if 3000 is usually of the
amount of it takes to move one server to
the cloud that used to be a lot more
when you're talking about a data center
Enterprise transformation exercise so
the cost has gone down but manually it's
still an extreme challenge right how do
you walk in to your clients today and
talk about one server costing $3,000
from a services perspective to move to
the cloud
that's how many months it'll take to
after a manual process of moving this
more clothing to plow right 35 months to
break even and then you talk about 80
percent of the of the team will fail to
achieve what the client is looking for
right so what does this tell you it
costs a lot of money you but it'll take
you three years to break even and your
customer will be unhappy 80 percent of
the time
why let's go to business together all
right that sounds like a winning
strategy right No
so the reality is automation solves
challenges at scale I was preaching this
eight years as a head of my startup I
still continue to preach it automation
allows me to have repeatability it
solves for human error and it can
actually save and retire a significant
return on investment so how do we do it
right
what are we consider what are the
challenges right so part about our
platform did and still continues to do
as part of the LOI let's look at these
factors when planning and addressing
some of these challenges right so the
first thing you want to do and I always
tell people this my successes in my past
life and up until today planning is a
significant part of any successful
engagement I believe 80% of your
successful engagement comes from
planning right it doesn't matter if you
have a magic tool doesn't matter if you
have a genius that can make servers work
magically right it's planning because I
can give you a great weapon and I don't
show you how to use it
you might point it at yourself right so
really from a strategic perspective that
the planning is critical and so how do
we approach this right so the first
thing that we do and we'll start all the
way to the left
well my left your right is comprehensive
affinity reporting what does that mean
okay
through the automation
we're gonna go ahead and map all the
interconnectivity from your application
stack now you might say and you guys are
technologists I you know mostly people
here are technologists well we have
monitoring tools we have all kinds of
stuff right you're right there's a lot
of tools that do certain jobs but what
we did was create one tool to do one job
okay so if you're trying to put a screw
into a wall and I'm not very handy okay
in my earlier days I use a hammer cuz
I'm just lazy right I know it's got a
little star thing in it right but he's
still having that picture in can't you
the minute you hand me that screw into a
wall and you hang a picture on it you
know it falls down right because that
screw should not have been hammered in
but just like anything else we want to
use hammers to lay in screws right so
we'll we'll get a monitoring solution
and say oh that'll help me do my my
affinity mapping the real the reality is
is that you really need the right tool
for the right job so in this in this
instance we actually designed this
technology for this specific exercise
and the exercise was trying to
understand how these applications are
communicating for the specific reason to
move them right we're not discovering it
because we think it's important we think
it's cool and it's great to know if
we're gonna move this application it has
to be connected and if it's connected to
something that also needs to move that's
how that was designed secondly it
removes subjective reporting what does
that mean everybody's been here work for
a company turnover right attrition
people leave information leaves with
people I can't trust the third
generation guy who owns an application
he's just been managing that he didn't
build I don't say I can't trust him but
he probably doesn't trust himself right
I think I know how this thing works
well you don't want to bet your career
on what somebody think they may know
about somebody else's work so what this
does is it eliminates the process of
guessing or interviewing a gentleman
about a potential application stack the
need for a comprehensive view of the
current fire environment or maintain
current state infrastructure everybody
ever had I'm sure everyone's use the
CMDB to do work everyone in here CMDB I
go to clients all the time and I say
okay let me see your CMDB they usually
give me the CMDB like this I sent you
the CMDB okay that's how they do it that
is not very confidence-building when I
have to plan a transformation on a
banking client that has me that can't
suffer any downtime okay
that's their CMDB so I really don't want
to trust it so what I do is I basically
through the collection period I create a
up to date inventory of the client's
infrastructure that's significant it
might sound like it's easy I'll give you
a real true case scenario I went to a
client they had 10,000 servers we
discovered 10,000 servers just not the
10,000 they told us about that was a
really funny interesting story i sat
down and said customer here's 7,000 of
your servers we can't find the 3000 the
clients like we have 10,000 I said well
we found seven and they said well what
about these they did the same thing
here's 3000 more service can you look at
those next thing you know we reconciled
their environment the client was happy
now they have a plan but imagine that
the same client would have went off
their CMD beach to do any type of
transformation activity they would have
a complete disaster
so the mapping portion and planning for
us are significant okay outside of
clouds servers are underutilized about
43 percent all right we all know what
VMware you
to be okay everybody here who ever gonna
VMware person I was certified in VMware
in my past what do we do
we are templates all right we got
template ABCD efg we were coordinating
build environments and a template Iowa
well that means we have these giant
servers that we're not really using and
maximizing do we want to bring that same
platform to cloud right and the reason
why I'm talking about this this is not a
exercise in manually building
infrastructure right we don't do that
we want to use the cloud automation we
want to use scripting we want to use our
technology to build out this
infrastructure we do not want to repeat
our failure on-premise and cloud so by
by mapping it we're gonna tell you how
your current subscription your servers
are being currently utilized so that you
can size your servers appropriately for
future state that's important because
first of all it cuts down cost
immediately I'll give an example anybody
here who look uses Microsoft sequel
licensing for instance your licensing is
attached to the size of your book server
that you're moving if I move a server
that I'm using 43% of and I have
multiple cores and multiple deaths in
CPU my Microsoft licensing costs are
this high you can get in front of your
customer and change not only the the way
that their compute is being consumed or
how much of it but save costs to the
customer with their cloud adoption move
so you can take that same conversation
and take it from a technology
perspective which is the conversations I
used to have and moving into a business
perspective and conversations around
taking money back into your own business
that's differentiation right so let's
look at what we did and what we did so
let's now do we moved on from there
here's the other thing I want to make a
point about when we do the mapping we
also when we reset we right size the
instance right because it talked about
utilization we also meant we also
monitor performance metrics CPU RAM disk
to determine if they need a specialized
am I should they use a disk intensive am
I should they use a an am i that is for
cpu intensive to whatever the we
prescribe you're the customers getting
already the benefits of cloud almost
immediately after they get there right
so we're cutting costs we're cutting
down their stock they're there they're
on compute footprint and then we're also
saving the money from licensing but
we're also saving the money off the size
of the instances they're out there
they're provisioning so it's a
significant differentiation so let's
talk about migrating so one of the
things that we used to do and this was a
TA it means any to any was that we're
here at Google store any to Google today
right but part of the platform were mute
removes the dependency on infrastructure
so that the client is on AWS they can
come to Google the VMware to Google
Google back it doesn't really matter we
can support portability between any
infrastructures so that was that's a big
difference so there's no vendor lock so
you're really gonna get the best value
for cloud not just from a cost
perspective but a performance
perspective so I don't I don't want to I
don't want to put you on the Walmart of
clouds right we don't want to go in that
direction what we want to do is balance
balance capability and cost those are
the kind of conversations you can have
with your customers now I've been at
Google for years I know what that cloud
is capable of right but that doesn't
mean they're the market leader from a
consumption perspective so there's some
conversations that we could have about
how the client can save money and take
advantage of Kyle capability now
manually migrated caught a server is ten
times more intensive I've been there
I've done manual migrations those are
the last things you want to do because
of the complexity the the chance that it
could fail those are things you don't
want to do so with automation it also
cuts down costs it reduces the effort
right I'll give you an example
month girls about two months ago I was
in India and we were doing a launch and
we migrated a thousand servers and I
think the whole process you know there
weren't big servers but it was like 18
minutes to light up to launch and they
all finished you know within seven to
eight hours thousand that's a lot of
service nope no Enterprise is gonna do
that but we did it in our environment
just to see what our capabilities were
but just imagine scale the chat that
what you can solve when you really
remove barriers such as human breast
sleep and food right so there's no
eating on datacenter floors if you got
automation right so there you go now oh
gods this is going backwards that's one
make sure I've been talking this long
all right sometimes I forget how long I
talk so as far as management so one of
the other things that we talked about
with cloud is every time you have a
cloud platform there's a cloud console
there's a management portal there's a
skills transfer there's guys who need to
know you know if you have a multi cloud
approach you have Google experts you
have VM guys on-premise you may have
another cloud provider so when you have
the capability of Management you're able
to manage across all platforms have one
single pane of glass so with the product
and the capabilities that we have at
Deloitte we're able to provision
Greenfield brownfield portableapps move
applications we're building out in our
roadmap micro services conversions from
VMware so we can automatically takes a
virtual machines convert them into micro
services and different types of
containerization platform so those are
the some of the things that we're
thinking about for the future and then
of course we have our own mitigate
platform which is a DR platform which is
currently running on a competitive cloud
but we are bringing that to Google in
the future so what are the Lloyds cloud
capabilities for migration perspective
we talk about the journey right the
client already normally has decided what
they want to do they don't may not know
where they want to go
so those are the kind of conversations
we want to have with our customers build
what's best right I'm a proponent on
movement and transition but that doesn't
mean that lifting ship is the only way
to get there obviously there's multiple
different ways you can reap lat form we
can rebuild applications you can
optimize and cloud all of those outcomes
are possible when you have a
multi-tiered approach and then
advancement in operations one of the
biggest issues I've seen in cloud it's
not cloud it's not technology its people
right where are the people to run this
and manage this environment I assume
some of you guys in the audience today
but the reality is the biggest obstacle
I've seen to change is the customer team
right we have the leadership team that
won't cloud we have the business that
one's cloud but cloud is a new job right
where are the skills where other people
that can manage us how do we transition
that conversation to our team to educate
them on how to support manage and
understand the DevOps kind of cloud
approach versus a typical infrastructure
approach and then and that's from a
perspective of advancing operations so
we talk about initiating engaging
converged mobilised in an adoption scale
that's all cloud and what cloud does but
getting there is the challenge and
that's what we were talking about with
our product set so what is a migration
like lifecycle this is our product set
as it was designed prior to acquisition
and this is actually how it lives inside
our Deloitte Services team now phase one
as we talked about is our application
analysis migration prioritization
migration prioritization is significant
I'm gonna talk about a little bit about
that today
migration prioritization is what happens
when you plan on migration that means
you may have thousands of workloads
you're not going to move your SI p
workloads on day one of your migration
plan okay that's not happen
I know you guys want to do that but no
you can't do it so prioritization will
allow you to and this is to automation
we will tell you which workloads are
easy to go first okay that's significant
because it's going to enable your team
that no have the answer okay guys we're
moving we're moving our enterprise in 50
waves the first three you know these are
the waves at least is how they're going
to be broken down will actually give you
a plan on how to execute your
transformation safely automated
infrastructure announcement talked about
that right performance metrics we talked
about sizing right sizing we talked
about you know what cloud is best suited
for your workload right we'll even tell
you a cost analysis on how each workload
you go group or cluster is best suited
price-wise for each cloud because at the
you know at the end of the day when the
rubber hits the road you have to have a
conversation of cost with the customers
you have to understand that's gonna be a
conversation well we're going to be able
to provide that for you readiness
planning so we talked about this a
little bit of earlier as well
migration task force setup right we're
gonna put a team together wave planning
we talked about that security and
governance right when you get to the
cloud you still have security concerns
right you still have maybe even more
security concerns than you had on
premise
all of that is important and party a
strategy of planning right so you before
you move right you have to have the
house set up you have to have the
foundation set up I I always talk about
migration as the essentially the movers
right but you don't consult the movers
until you have a house all right you
have a foundation you have walls you
have plumbing you have electricity once
that's all set up that's your security
that's your governance you gotta put
that doors in the front of your house
before you move your furniture in so all
of that is significant foundational
services planning what are you planning
to do when you get to the cloud right
what is your plan what is your strategy
is it just a lift and shift
infrastructure-as-a-service are using
pass are using database as a service all
of those things
all those conversations need to have
been had and everything needed have them
set up pilot landing zone build-out it
is what you know as described pilot
right you got to prove this concept
actually it's viable before you make a
wholehearted decision for to move to the
cloud and then migrations French we talk
about you know the waves the execution
all of that is part of our readiness
planning then we talk about execution
and all of the products I talked about
here a division a demotion handle that
this is really the the next level the
future of what we feel what we're cloud
is going to go from a transformation
perspective part of our phase three is
OS transformation part of the
capabilities in the platform allow you
to transform workloads
to different types or instance you can
take a red hat on premise and convert it
to sent to Wes on Google okay you can
take AWS Linux and convert it and to
sent to OS or Red Hat running on Google
that's significant that's the AWS
thought they were in the game when
they've created Amazon Linux
well we cracked the code and we can take
Amazon Linux and convert it into sent an
array there it happened that's huge
because now the monopoly in the vendor
lock is a completely broken now I'll
give you an example we had a customer
that was a retail customer that wasn't
happy with their relationship with that
other provider I just mentioned they
needed to move the Google but they were
running AWS Linux power virtually
anybody know what pair of virtual VMs
are oh it's really ugly
okay Google doesn't support prior
version we remind we converted them to
HTM on Google on sent OS so they took
their whole enterprise migrated it off
put it on Google converted it converted
it from per a virtual to hvm VMs
and turned him into senator less on
google it's like magic really I didn't
do it personally but I really smart team
that came up with this capability right
so what else are we doing with transform
we're taking on premise databases like
Oracle and converting them so postgrads
a MySQL on databases of service
platforms that's the next level of
transformation so when we talk about
lifting chef we're changing the
vernacular right we're not just going to
take your workloads as is we're doing
conversions of Technology now so if
anybody snuck in here from any
competitive product I'm sorry you had to
hear that because that's at least three
years for work for you guys we're gonna
get started I think you should leave the
session now actually get started
immediately but that's where we're
headed right we're pushing the envelope
up stat right so all of the lift and
shift is still happening but we're gonna
change the game we're talking about
taking VMs as I mentioned earlier in
container rising them right to
automation not manual effort so we
already have guys working on this today
doing live projects today where they're
going and clients and container izing
their network their their infrastructure
through automation huge so this is where
all the fun's happening so when you
asked me about the transition in the
acquisition this is the fun I'm gonna
happen the next couple years here at
Deloitte is is moving the envelope and
challenging all the other providers in
our space to meet that challenge
and then finally mirror cutover so
enterprise workloads are extremely
complex we all know this essay Peaks
tremely combat highly transactional how
do we move them right we're listed as
one of the only providers globally that
is verified by multiple cloud providers
as a tool of technology of choice for
SAT workload and the reason why is this
mirror so part of our engine constantly
mirrors Delta changes to technology the
workloads as
running live so we migrate all these
complex workloads live and we're
constantly synchronizing them so when
we're ready to flip the switch while I
you're on the other side of the fence it
didn't take you a 3-hour cut over window
and your enterprise workloads are intact
we only moved over 2000 s ap workloads
in the last 18 months so when people
talk about how hard s ap is to move we
just do it it's like everyday work for
us so we don't have a problem because
that's how the architecture was defined
design so this looks like an infomercial
for my company but it's really not it's
really dope the likes let us say you
know and I keep seeing this all over
again but the the I've actually walked
through many of this stuff already but
we talked about projections migrate
manage and then of course we have our
old disaster recovery product all data
guard which is running on a competitive
cloud today which will be moved over to
Amazon to Google all right so all of
these modules we talked about discovery
motion transform sphere and guard they
all fit under one platform it's called
atmosphere right so atmosphere is the
central brain of the platform that
allows you to control all of these
manuals he had to leave because he had
three hours he has three years to catch
up on I think I saw his vas he
immediately took a picture and left no
I'm just go you better hurry up just
think I told you guys to start anybody
else needs to leave and start developing
you better hurry up and leave now
they're gonna fall behind but but anyway
so the module the platform sits on top
of of all of these modules and allows
you complete control over everyone so
when we talk about a single pane of
glass
imagine one pane of glass and you can
see all your compute and have the
ability to move it
create right or protect your entire
computer that's why I also would be a
big VMware fan and that's why I came up
with a discrete because vSphere vSphere
could have done this they would have
been they would have been great now
they're on everybody else's cloud what
does it tell you see our decisions how
you make your decisions to depend on how
you end up but this would have been a
significant advantage for them so we
that was my vision one single pane of
glass controlled the entire
infrastructure complete visibility
complete control key management that's
power right so you can creat your your
virtual subnets you can create virtual
private clouds and other environments
you can move your will compute anywhere
you want without bringing it down future
so what do we collect and this allows
you to see the entire environment but
this is some of the reporting we give
you this is visible this is
visualization these are outputs these
are the cost comparisons this is all the
hosts data that's collected so it's a
significant amount of granularity so
when I tell people when you look at this
it's not just for executives a lot of
these views are not just executive
driven it's not a lot of picture
sometimes but when you are in the
trenches and you are trying to make
critical decisions you need facts and
you need detail right so instead of you
know I've seen other technologies or
other folks use spreadsheets a lot right
manually right before this remember I've
been in this a long time all right we
used to have spreadsheets and we used to
talk to customers and interview them and
we start write all this down that was
planning think about how brought would
error that is I can't even make out a
set of L's that a1 is that as oh Zetas
here I don't know right all of these
stuff is to automation so the
technology's not going to fudge the the
letter it's not going to tell you
something that's incorrect
that's that's why you can lay your head
and hat down on automation many times
it's because once you figure it out it
becomes a repeatable process you can
execute so we went through this and this
is just more granularity I'm giving you
guys so 20 hours to complete manual
migrations right we're talking about one
by one right maybe you build a server
right you're provision a server you
should stall the application you move
the data you watch it move it gets there
you validate it you turn up the app okay
we're done okay I'm next service well
when you can do crunches at a time or
even dozens at a time it takes that
effort for three hours and then you just
repeat it so the same 10 servers where I
can say I'm a great 30 servers took 3
hours that's 90 servers in 3 hours even
though you break it down by hours it's
the same number of hours it took to do
manually you're doing 30 at a time
that's that's just simple mathematics as
far as efficiency is concerned also
secure deployment versatility all the
transfer is encrypted we use 256 bit
encryption inside your environment so
you already have a firewall you're our
protective networking someone in there I
was assuming and then we encrypt the
data transfer so we just add layer and
layer of security and in these types of
scenarios and then we talked about this
this is important I tell people all the
time
anybody can migrate a web server that
doesn't impress me I see it all the time
I see demos real cute demos where a
small you know products to say look we
migrate a server in 15 minutes I'm like
wow that's pretty impressive what was it
running Bugzilla you how come y'all get
all laugh at that it's ok
bugzilla is that's a laughable comment
but the reality is
somebody tells you they're migrating
Oracle RAC in 15 minutes that's when you
take them out back for lying to you and
thrash them you get the rational to say
but that's that that's the reality the
reality is the enterprise is the
challenge Bugzilla not so much a
challenge so how easy is this to do well
I designed this product a long time ago
for anyone to use it because my
challenge was and I just to give me my
little background I was working
development I was a storage architect I
was a networking architect I was a
Windows Architect I was a Linux
architect I was an AIX architect and I
don't mean to brag that means I didn't
have any lights that's not really
something you should be proud of but
what it helped me realize is that every
time I got in the room with all of these
people everybody thought theirs was more
important than the next guy and that's
the reason why I learned it because when
I was in the Windows everybody
disrespects the Windows guy everybody
knows that is only nose guy he needs
pictures right then the Linux died oh we
don't like him cuz he really doesn't
know Unix he had to learn Linux alright
that's not real UNIX so then I knew the
UNIX guy and the UNIX guy was like oh no
I'm at the storage guy oh that guy he
had all the power because everything was
running on high performance storage and
who cares what the operating system was
right so I learned all of their towers
so I can sit in the room and tell them
to shut up and this is how we're gonna
do it I'm gonna eliminate all your jobs
I'm going to create an interface so
simple windows guy can do a migration
for Unix oh they didn't like that but
when they saw it they couldn't say
anything about it cuz actually work and
that's what so when you talk about what
made me do it
I got tired of the egos and I got tired
of the arrogance there's a lot of that
in our field right and you guys have
been in rooms with really smart people
they didn't have to be jerks to like
they were smart they earned it but I got
tired of that so I created this platform
so I could say look how easy it is for
this windows guy on the helpdesk to
migrate an AI excel part to the file and
we actually did that so what do we do we
made things simple we created one
profile one visibility one view we
created all the a priori hooks to twenty
different clouds and nine hypervisors
twenty different clouds not hypervisors
I'm talking about clouds you probably
don't even care about right
CenturyLink anybody care about Central
and nobody for CenturyLink but there
used to be a big cloud they still are
they still have a footprint but that's
the reality reality is we can go
anywhere anywhere there were close
that's where we are
Sahra flair Alibaba I mean I don't want
to try too many names at the Google
conference but we know there are the
clouds all right let's talk about
hypervisors KVM citrix right let's talk
about hyper-v let's talk about VMware
the NMR had a big foothold on this
business a long time ago it's slipping
right so how about an interface that
lets you migrate between all those
platforms to API so easy the guys to
help desk could do it that's what we did
right so case study what do we do we
talked about the big number right the
big number is easy when you don't have
limitations right the way our product
was designed and built was peer to peer
that means the workload process
transformation exists between source and
target so as long as the pipe is big
enough there's no processing power of
being utilized by our product it's all
distributed in the architecture that
means if I have a thousand workloads
there's a thousand pairs they're talking
amongst themselves they're transferring
the data amongst themselves they set up
a client-server architecture amongst
themselves that's how you scale because
you don't care about dependencies of
infrastructure there is no worry about
hey do I have to create a
library to store my images and then
deploy so any of our competitors that
are still here I haven't left to start
developing I think we lost three or four
guys they had to go start so to the rest
of you guys who are gonna fall behind if
you don't leave right now
it's a peer-to-peer infrastructure that
means every compute instance is running
their own transformation amongst itself
I think that's pretty cool I eliminated
the whole problem one of the biggest
problems was the device had to sit there
and manage all these migrations well if
you eliminate that and you spread the
compute all through the whole migration
guess what there's no bottleneck other
than bandwidth so once we procure the
bandwidth that's when you hear terms
like unprecedented that's when you hear
words like unprecedented oh I never
heard of that it's impossible now keep
in mind before we were acquired we just
do this magic all the time and we would
tell people about it and they'd say
you're lying you're lying it's
impossible so now that we're not have to
deal with that anymore we didn't do all
kinds of magical things so there you go
so I don't know how many startups ran
here I hope there's a couple it's
possible to build magical things and
eventually people start to believe it so
this is the use case I'm sure it's
downloadable but this is stuff we talked
about dashboards strategy 30 million
costs 55,000 client developers on GCP so
so big financial company probably heard
of them so what's happening so our
biggest thing is partnering with the GCP
platform with Deloitte with added data
now to to explode and to do the
unprecedented right anybody can do the
press identity
but can you do the unprecedented that's
what we're shooting for that's what
we're planning to do that's our goal and
now that we you know we're established
we have the capabilities we have the
backing we have the platform to land
that's what we're looking to do and
obviously the the capability is there
now we have the consultancy with the
Lloyd obviously the lawyer has obviously
a significant investment and providing
the cloud services and now they have the
platform and technology to do it so
anyway guys thank you I'm 10 minutes
early guys any questions please see me
afterward I appreciate your time today
thank you
[Applause]
you
[Music]